je vous présenter il y a quelques
semaines le Edge 40 pro de Motorola
voici qui viennent de sortir le Edge 40
alors il sera un peu moins speaké un
tarif moins cher à 599 € alors ici vous
allez avoir un écran incurvé qui va être
incurvé sur le côté sur deux côtés la
droite et la gauche une dalle P o lait
de 6,55 pouces résolution Full HD + et
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement
qui va jusqu'à 144 Hertz de caméra grand
angle ultra grand-angle ici il y a pas
de téléobjectif une batterie de 4400
milliampères heure et de la recharge
rapide 68 watts des haut-parleurs stéréo
Dolby Atmos vous tournez sur Android 13
avec deux ans de mise à jour Android 14
Android 15 et 3 ans de mise à jour de
sécurité et il tourne sur un processeur
de médiathèque c'est un dimensity 800020
bien évidemment 5G avec 8 Go de RAM et
256 Go de stockage autant vous dire
qu'ici vous pouvez en mettre quand même
pas mal dedans je vous l'ai dit tout ça
599 €, je trouve plutôt cool à voir bien
évidemment à tester plus tard d'ailleurs
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez sur le
papier comment vous le trouvez est-ce
que vous avez déjà eu un smartphone de
Motorola et est-ce que ce smartphone
pourrait vous faire de l'oeil marquez
moi ça bien évidemment dans les
commentaires